where would you put
khabib in the discussion of the greatest
of all time so you recently
we worked together we watched the fight
um
of him and um justin gaichi and and
khabib retired
would you put him up there as some of
the as one of the greatest or did he
never truly find his foil that like the
great warrior that challenged him
and um and maybe do you want to do you
think he's fully retired now
to answer the question about being fully
retired i don't have any idea
i can't for a second pretend to um
think that i understand the way that
people from that part of the world think
and respect their family and things like
that
to an american who says oh i promised my
mom i wouldn't do it i mean i promised
my mom i wouldn't do a lot of things and
i went right out
[ __ ] back door and did them yeah but
i think that that means something
different to people in different parts
of the world
so i have no idea what kind of weight
that carries
so i can't answer that i can say
a lot of times when people think about
great fighters they think about the
aspects that make up
mma like they think of mma as a pie
and they're all these different pieces
that make up for make up the pie
and how good is this piece and how good
is this piece and how good is this piece
when the fact of the matter is is you
only need one
really really really good piece and the
other pieces are complementary pieces to
get you
to where you're the strongest and if you
want to tell me
that khabib's not the greatest mma
fighter because he doesn't have really
slick striking
you can make that argument but what i
can tell you is khabib has good
enough striking to get him to his
grappling where he is clearly the best
guy at 155 they've ever seen
yeah so does that make him the greatest
fighter at that division or not
you